Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so agents of shield
video as requested.
There is some grade a creepy stuff happening
on show right now so this can be a theory
video involving the Spider-Man comics as well
as some of the stuff that's been happening
in the movies in the TV shows I will be doing
a lot more bonus Easter egg, comic book videos
during the break that were getting ready for
so be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Make sure you click that bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss out now I'm going to play
these clips from agents of shield just to
give you a little bit of context and then
explain what's going on shield.
Once you see what I'm creating all show the
wall for guns on this was yo-yo Daisy and
rest of the biggest because we have everyone
coming because the devil is fired or course
on the table is in android she's just happy
for this okay I forgot about the fact that
is mildly attractive to her that totally goes
against the Sokovia accords on anyone remember
all trot was reckless doing so much time.
The point is a good directory should know
what assets she has at his disposal in this
case I think it could be an asset a risky
one, but it's your call may go to Doctor Rocco
Slavin get data on on this mission will dismantle
her afterwards about my salty got the green
light to Coulson Daisy is some Doctor strange
they explained that they harness the energy
from other dimensions to use their magic.
That's where their power comes from.
We learned that you can also harness energy
from the dark dimension to gain even more
power at the cost of your soul the power you
gain to the dark cold is also the same deal
you start reading through the pages you gain
knowledge you give up your soul.
So it's all heading in that direction, but
right now in the comics there's actually a
really interesting dark cold story going on
in the carnage solo title Kletus Kasidy learned
about a prophecy in the dark cold that describes
him and he feels like it's a prophecy that
he's meant to set could Thawne freak he's
the writer of the dark old he's a class I
demon one of the elder gods of the Marvel
universe.
So basically like the worst possible thing
that could happen.
Carnage is meant to unleash it on the marvel
universe, so something similar is probably
also happening on agents of shield but were
at the midseason finale.
So it's a little early for somebody that big
to manifest.
That like the kind of thing you'd say for
a series finale.
Even the Doctor strange movie only lightly
touched on the idea of door mambo they did
over explain it, you just learned that he
is the conqueror of dimensions he just goes
from reality to reality, making everything
that exists is so on shield.
Eli Morrow is calling himself the God just
because he's infused with this power he can
seemingly create matter out of nothingness
but really he just become a conduit for this
other dimension that he's pulling energy from
in the theory is is that, because of what
happens to everyone that tries to use the
dark cold there is some power that will try
to manifest in our reality now it looks like
he's kind of building a gateway to, they just
did that in the recent episode you saw like
a version of marvels hell that's usually Mephisto.
But there are hell lords.
So there are number of people that could poke
back out from the darkness.
You have people like the satannish you even
have dormammu although I don't think that
the TV show would do dormammu just because
of the links that Doctor strange had to go
to even contact him.
I feel like Dormammu was going to stay and
movie villain for now but they might reference
him on the TV show the dark hold itself is
mostly connected to could Thawne the person
that wrote it, but he's also known as the
demon of the dark cold the great shadow.
So if you're big Joss Weeden fan and you're
waiting for like some mystery giant terrible
figure to manifest from a dark portal.
It would be the demon of the dark old but
on the flipside of this, let's talk about
the old Tron part of this she's not name else
I am Ada is making herself a brain which looks
a lot like the AI consciousness from Avengers:
Age of Ultron just the way they made that
look with the CG.
So I don't think that she's actually going
to become old Tron, but she is making herself
a brain to enhance her power to enable her
to fully take advantage of what the dark hold
offers.
So the likely scenario in that case is a very
similar old Tron situation where she just
totally does not buy in to what all the humans
want like she feels like she knows better
old Tron thought of the humans is a cancer
on the earth.
So he wanted to get rid of them like the title
of the last episode deals with our devils,
Ada even if she does gain this super dark
old brain will be the only person who could
buy Eli Morrow.
So you send a God to fight a God she slowly
becoming a God in her own right, which we
learned from all Marvel movies and comics
always ends terribly for everyone but just
like Dormammu Moo and Doctor strange carnage
in the demon of the dark cold in the comics.
Eli Morrow looks like he's going to unleash
chaos on the world if he successful.
The funny thing in the comics is is the teaser
for like the next episode of agents of shield
is the exact same carnage is beginning to
unleash could Thawne just is Eli Morrow's
getting ready to activate his mystery box
to hell, so let me know what you guys think
is going on.
Do you think this is going to be like the
comics.
Eli Morrow will unleash the demon of the dark
cold or though use some other character on
the TV show.
The only thing that stops people short from
talking about people like Mephisto or Dormammu
Moo on the TV shows as you know like what
can they do in the movies.
What does Marvel have the rights to the interesting
difference between marvels TV shows in its
movies is that the rights are little bit different,
so there are like movie rights for things
then there are television rights, so they
could do a character in the movies just because
another studio has the rights that doesn't
mean that they couldn't do that character
on television gets a little messy when you
talk about that so I have a feeling that what
shield will actually do is the find some clever
work around where the be like a dark persona
but you won't actually manifest it look like
somebody from the comics because like the
demon of the dark cold looks kind of like
this Cthulhu like figuring of tentacles on
his head in the kind of did that last season
with hive and asked if she finally succeeded
in defeating money to remain.
So don't if the gonna recycle that look usually
characters that are this powerful like Dormammu
Moo are scarier when you don't give them a
full physical form that's kind of the reason
why they did that in Doctor strange just explained
that the only reason he would take physical
form was for the benefit of Doctor strange
when he came to approach them otherwise beings
like Dormammu Moo can exist in whatever state
they want they could be like a scary glow
cloud.
It just the big low clouds are kinda boring
to watch in a big hundred $50 million movie
but the winter finale for agents of shield
is happening next week so I'll be doing a
video for that they're also doing the winter
finale's for the DC TV shows to, so let me
know what kind of bonus videos you guys want
me to do during the midseason break the be
a lot of comic book stuff let me know if you
want me to finish that carnage dark old story
is actually pretty cool.
The artwork is great and it's written by Jerry
Conway who created a lot of the comic book
characters that they use on the DC TV shows
right now.
So just funny to see like such a big comic
book writer this time so much DC work do like
a really cool marvel story so next video will
be the new guardians of the Galaxy trailer
that will post tonight get hype it can be
awesome while you guys wait for that to post
you can click here for my breakdown of the
last guardians trailer and you can click here
for my breakdown of the Spider man footage
they showed off yesterday.
Thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!